RETO MEIER: Today
we're talking about
industry-leading security, AI
solutions, study materials,
and science.
I'm Reto, and welcome to "This
Week in Cloud," where we serve
you the lowest-latency news.
At Google Cloud,
we defend your data
against threats and
fraudulent activity
using the same infrastructure
and security services
we use for our own operations.
Our goal is to be the
most effective partner
as you transform your
business for a digital world,
whether your system's running
Google Cloud, in other clouds,
or on-prem.
Our trusted cloud enables
your digital transformation
while also supporting your
security transformation.
Check out the post for specifics
of our three new trusted cloud
requirements-- a
secure platform that
delivers transparency and
enables sovereignty, a proven
zero-trust architecture,
and shared fate,
not shared responsibility.
Google Cloud offers
lots of products
to support a wide
variety of use cases.
But how do you even
know where to start?
Don't worry, we've
got you covered.
The "4 Words or Less"
Google Cloud developers
cheat sheet describes
each Google Cloud
product in four words or less.
If you're just getting
started, this resource
gives you a quick
overview of all
that's available to
you on Google Cloud.
And if you're more
experienced, it
can be a great way to
identify new products that you
might want learn more about.
Download the PDF of
the latest version
at the links in the
description or on GitHub.
Gartner has named Google
a leader in its 2021
Magic Quadrant for Cloud
AI developer services.
We believe this recognition is
based on Gartner's evaluation
of Google Cloud's
language, vision,
conversational and structured
data services and solutions
for developers.
This recognition is also a
reflection of the confidence
and satisfaction that
customers have in our products,
from a cohesive AI
stack for developers
to purpose-built AI solutions
for industry use cases.
Check out the blog post for
more of what Gartner has to say.
Drawing on the experience
of our customers,
the Google Cloud
Born-Digital Summit
will offer practical
guidance on building
a resilient and scalable
foundation for great customer
experiences.
Over this half-day
event, we'll highlight
proven best-practice approaches
to data, architecture,
diversity, and
inclusion and growth
with Google Cloud solutions.
Born-Digital is an event
for app developers,
technology innovators,
and business leaders
who are disrupting the market
and shaping the future.
Check out the post to
register and learn more
about the March 25 event.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the cloud.